Tom Brady retiring from football for
good second time run emotional message
that he gave I wore his jersey yesterday
I don't want to spend a lot of time on
this thing here but obviously seeing him
make the announcement uh and now taking
a break to go with the family nobody
knows what he's going to be doing next
he's already got a massive contract for
himself it's a Once in a Lifetime uh
player to see what he did seven
championships the argument becomes the
following is should we moving forward
say he is the Brady of dot dot or should
we still say he is the Jordan of such
and such dude that's the biggest debate
and some people may even come in and say
wait a minute what you're talking about
is great but imagine being the greatest
player in the world of a sport that is
the most popular player sport in the
world which is soccer we should moving
forward say he is the message so what is
we have to we have to figure it out
right now the world has to follow okay
right now we have to figure it out okay
we're going to set the stand for
everybody is it Brady Jordan or Messi
moving forward in in in the world
because you're in soccer so like yeah in
the world in the United States of
America Brady or Jordan
I mean I grew up with Jordan so and that
was my that's my guy so as far as like
the greatest greatest greatest of
anything it's MJ it's not even a
question however why why do you say that
Brady left went to the Bucks and won a
Super Bowl with another team did Jordan
win a championship with the Wizards oh
you know what you're right Rob Michael
Jordan no no bueno you got me no you got
me wait I know what he's saying is
though but record-wise seven seven
championships went to a different team
to win I think the greatest in the world
is Messi I think in the United States I
gotta go in Jordan I'm sorry I'm a
Giants fan and we beat him twice well if
it wasn't for the New York Giants he'd
have two more Rings FYI I'll tell you
that you're welcome I'll tell you this
we can have that debate that's great
these are all this is this is Goat
Mountain right here yeah there's only
one the most eligible bachelor in the
world at this point that guy Thomas
Brady yeah number one so he doesn't need
to be on Bumble he doesn't need to be on
tender not at all he is
he is the honey to the beach
knees an honest question if he didn't
retire
I mean if he did go with the retirement
the first one would he still be married
probably yes are you serious that was
obviously the final score now yes that
was the straw that broke the camera you
know the same with the horses and the
camera I did a straw that broke the
camera I disagree by the way in in the
World of Sports
when a goat retires and they go from
that life to a day-to-day
the they're not used to seeing each
other as much as a part of why it worked
was because it was a part-time marriage
it's a full-time commitment but it's a
part-time I like that you know marriage
and bodybuilding that happens in
baseball and basketball and football I
mean pools you know Jordan you know so
you got so many of them you go through
very very few of them uh stay together
it's a very hard thing and so Tom Brady
with where she was I have a feeling that
we're having issues way before that on
the way they want to live different
Lifestyles and uh no I think uh I think
either way it would have just taken a
little longer that's my opinion but
anyway because you're saying Pat because
that time apart like with seasons for
the average person you can't have a
season it'd be cool like babe I need two
months let me tell you I gotta go Vinnie
you know when when when somebody says
something like this they'll say man I
would have loved if I would have worked
with uh Elon Musk I would freaking
killed it if I would have worked under
Steve Jobs I would have freaking killed
it you know if I if I had a teammate
Brady dude it would have been awesome
you know if I was married to Tom Brady
and I had a husband like him oh dude I
would do anything for the guy right
and then let's just say you do and
you're working for Steve Jobs what do
you think Steve Jobs would do do you
think he would sit there and say let me
sell you the vision of where Apple's
going to be in the future one day and
one day we're gonna build this machine a
computer is gonna fit in a small little
case like this and you would say what a
Visionary or do you think Steve Jobs
would say you guys got six months to fit
this big ass box and this or your fire
period okay all right so the point is
like you want to work for Steve Jobs
until you work for Steve Jobs and you
say this guy's a freaking Tyrant right
the hell is the matter with it and then
so you you're like I'd love to marry Tom
Brady oh Tom that'd be so freaking and
all of a sudden boom you're you're
Gisele uh my beautiful model you know
married to the guy Tom Brady and like
holy freaking [__] I want him to obsess
over me like all the other men I've ever
dated this guy loves football more than
me can be with a guy like that and chat
I don't want to be with a guy like this
and he'd go with a you know Jiu Jitsu
guy that's uh got an instructor who's
got more time to spend time with you
than a Tom Brady yeah there's a lot of
people that want to be guys with people
like this until you are with them and
they're like holy [__] maybe I should
have just married the other school
teacher and uh both of them don't work
by the way because you want the bad boy
and you want the school teacher and that
guy just doesn't exist okay anyways that
was more like a rant I love it I love no
but you're right you're right yeah yeah
by the one Jen and I were dating I told
her I said baby if you want a nine to
five guy I'm not it
if we went to a uh uh we went to a
counselor
and it's one guy Christian counselor who
the church was sent to and uh have you
heard me tell the story so we go to this
counselor and I said so tell me about
yourself yeah I'm uh you know my wife
and I've been married 33 years I'm
suppressed if somebody can take advice
from I said what's your secret sauce for
your marriage working out for 33 years
we have had dinner every night at six
o'clock we've never missed it I believe
that's the key to success I said what
business are you in oh I'm a school
teacher how about your wife she's also a
school teacher I said you know it's so
awesome meeting you here is a 200 babe
we gotta go yeah it was so uncomfortable
Jennifer's on comes like babe just let's
at least that's a no babe there's
nothing we can talk here yeah we're
getting the car says what was that all
about I said babe I'm not a school
teacher I'm not going to be home at six
o'clock dinner this is not the life you
want that at somebody else you don't we
want to go take over the world this is a
very different mentality but if you are
that person go pee it yeah it's
beautiful I'm just not a school teacher
I feel you but I think it's so important
what you're saying about having those
conversations up front like you
established early and often with Jen hey
I'm not that nine to five guy so what's
the um
what's the famous quote where it says
men wear married women hoping that they
will never change and that Women Marry
men hoping that they will change and
then invariably they'll both be
disappointed I think it's very it goes
It goes men marry women hoping they
don't change and they do women marry men
hoping they change and they don't right
yeah and they both end up disappeared so
I think if you establish what you were
just talking about up front Hey listen
I'm not that nine to five guy that's six
o'clock dinner thing every night I'm
just shooting a freaking video by six
o'clock I might not be home till eight
so like this is the guy you're going to
marry are you comfortable with that yeah
because I don't seven years down the
road I want to be like why are you never
home it's like I told you that up front
yeah and and going over your step
patches really really fast I think those
moments where you are like that time off
I'm not saying being away from your wife
forever but like that season that he's
gone and whatever I think it helps
because you know you're apart and then
when you see each other it's amazing but
if you're there every single day in the
person's face it's a little it's a
little too much yeah the fables never
match you know the fables and the
stories never match the reality and you
can read a lot of books and biographies
about Bezos about jobs uh loved the
story it was in the Forbes her Fortune
goes way back jobs is very frustrated By
A Thing Called mobile me remember about
12 15 years ago maybe longer than that
apple had a product called mobile me
it's not really working right hauls
everybody into a conference room who is
working on it so there's like apparently
about 100 people in there
and he points a product manager and he
says tell me
what mobile me
what the spec is what the product is
well mobile me is the game and he looks
at the guy and he said okay and they
said he said turn red and Steve Jobs
says well then why the flip doesn't it
do that
you're done and he points to his left to
two people they are leading the project
and he leaves the conference room ladies
and gentlemen that is the romantic view
exactly exactly exactly oh only if I you
know you know but by the way that whole
concept about you are the person you are
the average of five people you hang out
with there's typically the one guy in
that group that you don't like because
he's constantly challenging you and you
most people would have a very hard time
being friends with a guy like Steve Jobs
it's not a easy friendship it's good on
the outside it's tough on the inside
okay so if you enjoyed this clip you
want to see another one click here to
watch another clip and if you want to
take advantage the latest gold Signature
Series products that just came out we
have a bunch of new merch that's out
this is a color changing mug when you
drink coffee that lion turns into a real
lion and then we have hoodies with
vitamin gold on it the gold Signature
Series hat shirts I'm an entrepreneur
anyways we have a lot of items they're
selling out if you want to take
advantage the gold Signature Series
click here place your order Sports your
right taming gear and tag us with the
hashtag valuetainment
[Music]